the berserk is a fighter who knows no
fear they strike terror into the hearts
of their opponents and become a pillar
of strength for their allies this
ruthless savage cannot imagine a day
without a good fight
filled with rage they feel no pain and
dangerous wounds are never enough to
drive them off the battlefield the
berserkers mighty weapon is a huge
electric saw sword which can inflict
massive damage to enemies very quickly
and their crippling blow will
incapacitate even the most powerful
adversary crushing throw will toss the
enemy up in the air and smash them
violently against the ground
firestorm will scorch everyone within
range inflicting massive damage and the
tectonic blast ability will make the
ground around the furious warrior
explode erupting with streams of
devastating lava the Berserker can
easily cover a great distance with a
single leap quickly reaching and
crippling their enemies consumed by
battle frenzy the Berserker performs
carnage slicing their victim to shreds
their thundering roar will strike fear
into the hearts of even the bravest
but the greatest is that it comes from
the gladiator stance the flames of fury
around the berserker filled them with so
much power than trying to escape his
future the Berserker can single-handedly
crush a powerful enemy with an
overwhelming series of strikes want to
know more visit Skyforge dot-com